i'm a different person to be honest in
um i i think the kid that showed up at
the university of oregon is isn't me
anymore and um you know there's there's
aspects of my game that have changed
i've become more
vocal i've become more outgoing and
there are things that you have to do to
be to be a quarterback and the way the
quarterback carries himself um i think
that i've done a great job of becoming
that over these past four years
i will say this if the nfl draft were
based solely on hair justin herbert
would be the first overall pick and they
would shut it down
after one selection there would be no
one else worthy of even getting on the
stage justin herbert the oregon
quarterback that was at the podium the
other day he was here with chris sims
and me josh norris is in for chris today
who continues to be
under the weather i never understood
what that phrase means but we all know i
mean where it came from like under the
like what does that mean he's sick he's
sick he's got the flu the whole store's
got the flu hopefully the whole store
won't get the flu because he was here
passing it around on tuesday before he
got sick all right josh quarterbacks and
receivers working out tonight justin
herbert from oregon will be working out
joe burrow isn't tuatanga villa
recovering from the hip surgery isn't
who are you looking forward to seeing
doing their thing prime time tonight in
uh lucas oil stadium let's continue down
this justin herbert path uh you all saw
that he threw what 32 touchdown passes
last year i watched all six of his
interceptions
there were some red flags there mike um
this is a player who i don't know can
like make magic outside of structure
it's one who i think has to hit his back
foot than find the open receiver down
the field i know chris has loved the way
he throws the football i do too it's
he has lasers i mean there's plenty of
arm talent out there he he has the arm
to make every single throw but the
decision making at times and what really
stood out to me was all six
interceptions zero disruption so it was
just
what was going on in his mind a misread
a wrong decision in those moments that
caused the interception and that cannot
translate to the nfl and that's an
interesting point because in patrick
holmes we see the ultimate example of a
guy who
is really operating two plays the play
they call and then the play that he
pulls out of thin air or
from some other orifice when it all
falls apart and he makes it work we've
had the conversation this week about
kirk cousins right kirk cousins can't do
that and and i think okay so let me take
it this direction who are the guys from
this quarterback class that you believe
would have the ability to be more like
my homes where when it hits the fan they
can create they can be loose they can be
confident and they can make things
happen even if the intended play falls
apart yeah right now as we sit here in
late february only two it's joe burrow
and it's tua uh joe burrow consistently
showed that this year and everyone
talked about his small hands obviously
fumbling was an issue and he faced quite
a lot of disruption with lsu this year
but he's able to keep his eyes up in
those situations he certainly i wouldn't
call him as athletic as patrick holmes
certainly not as i thought as lamar
jackson a lot of these other
quarterbacks that can you know make
space and make plays happen outside of
structure but it it might be like a tier
below in aaron rodgers who is someone
who is very good at escaping out of the
backside or climbing up in the pocket um
and joe if you're a tear below aaron
rodgers right i mean this is no no i
just i've seen mobility okay but this is
the first overall pick in the draft i
mean that the thing with joe burrow that
confuses me yeah and i don't watch as
much college football as i could or
should because i'm traveling every
saturday to new york for what we do on
sunday but with joe burrow
you know this guy comes out of nowhere
right totally is
nowhere but if we go back it's not
exactly out of nowhere because being
recruited by ohio state is not out of
nowhere but i mean as a performer at the
college level it's one year it's 15-0
it's heisman trophy it's national
championship being you know the nfl
junior that is the sec there's a lot of
good there but i i you know for him to
and i i well let me ask you this if two
of tonga by law hadn't got her gotten
injured would he be the number one
overall pick over joe burrow i cannot
answer that question because george
tagovailoa did get hurt and you know
come on i'm serious i mean this is
both are quality players and i'm not
sure and we've heard only glowing
reports from tua's hip of course of
course we have and that's another
what-if scenario right so i'm not sure
if every team one they need a
quarterback right
two if they love tua it'll and three
if they have a clean medical on tua all
three of those have to align for him to
be a top five top ten selection and
that's the equation we don't know but
the other concern and gm told me this
when tua got injured three lower body
injuries at the college level if you
can't stay healthy at that level you are
not going to stay healthy at the next
level and if you're using mobility and
you're putting your heart yourself in
harm's way it's just going to keep
happening you mentioned one-year
quarterbacks kyler mitch trubisky a lot
of others recently have just been one
year as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports